so also jetzt müssten wir eigentlich
öffentlich mit diesem wunderbaren stream
sein oder eben nicht dann haben wir
nämlich einfach 0 zuschauer das ist doch
wirklich nicht zu fassen
hallo markus hallo das sage ich jetzt
nicht
luca hallo hallo hallo niko doch nein
der stream ist endlich öffentlich es ist
wirklich manchmal eine qual mit dem
backen youtube also wir haben gerade
schon stream
aber er kam irgendwie nicht über ja das
nicht gelistet sein hinaus herzlich
willkommen hier aus dem theo aus der
theodor storm grundschule in berlin
hier war ich gerade wählen denn das ist
unser thema wir können nämlich was tun
im anschluss an die zerstörung der cdu
und damit meine ich ausschließlich den
video titel ja ich bin journalist
deswegen werde ich nichts dazu sagen wen
ich gewählt habe ich werde keine partei
empfehlen oder von der wahl einer der
parteien abraten aber ich werde
inhaltlich was dazu sagen was die
parteien hier ja im vorfeld der
europawahlen so alles unternommen haben
und wofür sie stehen und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem leistungen den ich
ihnen hochkant mache ja ich glaube das
gar nicht so schlecht weil die meisten
von euch werden wahrscheinlich am handy
er unterwegs sein dann das nächste
dies vereinfacht ich habe sie jedenfalls
auf ios nicht ins querformat gebracht
bekommen also deshalb werden wir das
hier jetzt in hand machen
also ich war hier in der theodor storm
grundschule gerade wählen und das ist
nicht ganz einfach
jetzt haben wir genau da ist ein gang
zum wahllokal und hier hinten da kann
man auch noch wählen da in dieser
debatte mal hier hier hier ist es nicht
da da da da ist noch eine baracke da
kann man auch wählen also hier sind
verschiedene wahllokale und es ist
eigentlich ganz einfach man braucht
eigentlich nur seinen ausweis man sollte
wissen in welchem wahlbezirk mal
angemeldet ist das steht auf der
wahlbenachrichtigung die habe ich hier
zb so sieht das aus
ihr war nach richtiger und ja mit der
das steht was da drauf wo man genau da
sieht man es hin muss und da geht man
dahinter steht mal im wählerverzeichnis
dann wird der personalausweis
kontrolliert und dann welt waren und ich
kann da nur zu raten ist auch wirklich
zu tun weil ich habe schon auf instagram
gesagt wir sind das volk und das ist
keine forderung sondern es ist
tatsächlich so dass ist integraler
bestandteil der demokratie
das heißt wir haben heute die
möglichkeit als souverän unseres staates
wir sind quasi die königinnen und könige
von deutschland beziehungsweise heute
von europa und können wählen und
entscheiden damit wie sich das
europäische parlament zusammen setzt und
damit können wir auch wirklichen
massiven einfluss nehmen wenn wir heute
aus dem was in den letzten tagen
passiert ist die konsequenzen ziehen
wenn wir wenn wir zu jung sind nicht
wählen können aber mit unseren
großeltern mit unseren eltern freunden
verwandten bekannten also greift zum
telefon ruft die an und sagt hey habt
ihr schon gewählt weil das finde ich
auch ein ganz wichtiger punkt das ist
unsere bürgerpflicht wir sind meines
erachtens dann noch danach dazu
verpflichtet zu wählen weil wird damit
eben unsere macht ausüben und wären für
die nichtwähler gehört er muss damit
leben dass er die besonders kleinen und
oft auch extremen parteien unterstützt
die nämlich ihre mitglieder viel besser
mobilisieren können
und ja und dann im notfall eine politik
mit verstärkt für die er gar nicht
eintritt das heißt also unbedingt wählen
gehen es ist nicht so kompliziert die
entsprechenden wahllokale sind meistens
irgendwo um die ecke und ja und es ist
ganz leicht da sein kreuz zu machen gibt
41 parteien zwischen denen man sich hier
unterscheiden muss man hat ein kreuzchen
zu machen man kann sogar parteien machen
dass es gibt nicht wie bei der
bundestagswahl abgeordnete die man
wählen kann und parteien sondern es gibt
nur die stimme für die parteien ja und
hier entsteht ja schon eine sehr bunte
diskussion zum thema was man wählen soll
ich kann nur sagen es muss eine partei
sein wie sich massiv
dafür einsetzt dass wir jetzt massiv
etwas gegen den klimawandel tun
wir müssen unbedingt den co2 ausstoß
weiter senken also wir brauchen ein
kohleausstieg der mindestens bis 2030
abgeschlossen ist nicht wie 2038 was er
jetzt die bundesregierung beschlossen
hat
wir brauchen die einhaltung der
klimaziele die beschlossen worden sind
im pariser klimaabkommen dh bis 2020
diese auch wirklich was man kann sich da
jemand der hier immer fdp kann ich nicht
raus zogen den kann ich nicht entfernen
nutzergruppe vorübergehen blockieren ja
super so was sollte ich sagen ja also
solche parteien müssen wir wählen
warum sich denn jetzt jetzt jetzt
kommentar stream wieder da hatte man da
auch noch mal ich muss mich jetzt gerade
ein bisschen hier betätigen was die
kommentare angeht so das ist ja auch
immer ein bisschen arbeit das muss jetzt
alles hier selber machen
man kann dieses studium mit kameras und
sonst was er sonst ab und zu mal haben
sondern es ist nur mein iphone und ich
die hier aus der theodor storm
grundschule hier in neukölln in berlin
ja berichten
ich will mir geht es gar nicht um
parteien geworden sind sondern leute die
alles zu stemmen so und wenn das eine
partei ist ja da ständig gesperrt wird
dann kommt die ebenso aber ist auch
nicht so schlimm
wir wissen alle welche parteien er so
die klimaziele verfolgen und wer das
unterstützt und da muss man ja sagen
dass die das wichtig witzige ist ja nach
der ganzen diskussion über die
zerstörung der cdu das ja viel
kritisiert worden sagt populismus
gewesen und er hätte ja nur sich dass
kraus gesucht was eben gefallen hätte
aber am schluss kam raus ich geh jetzt
mal langsam
durch die stadt am schluss kam raus dass
er doch am besten recherchiert hat sie
nämlich das pdf was die cdu
veröffentlich hatte das war noch viel
viel als wobei ich sagen muss sowieso
hand und recherchiert aber das was das
pdf als die cdu dann veröffentlicht hat
war noch schlimmer es war noch
schlechter recherchiert es war noch ich
sag mal da war ganz viel rausgesucht
was ist damals eher tendenziell die cdu
in einem besonders guten licht
dargestellt hat aber viele ich sag mal
so fanden die sogar aufgestellt haben
die stimmten zwar im detail schon aber
im großen und ganzen nicht zum beispiel
was die entwicklung der bildung in
deutschland angeht was die entwicklung
der altersarmut angeht die ist um 50
prozent zb gestiegen
also die cdu hat sich dort in einem
licht dargestellt wo man einfach sagen
muss das kommt hier nicht zu und ich
will hier eben nicht weitermachen mit
der mit der tierschutz matschewski sich
in die kommentare als zu eins mit dem
cdu bashing
es gilt für viele parteien dass sie sich
deutlich besser darstellen als sie
eigentlich sind und ja und deshalb muss
man will ich eben nicht für eine partei
hier werbung machen sondern einfach
sagen geht wählen es ist unsere
bürgerpflicht und wir sollten das
unbedingt tun
ja und das ist das ist auch noch mal
eine ganz wichtige information dass ist
die letzte wahl die wir jetzt haben in
der noch der klimawandel in irgendeiner
weise aufgehalten werden kann
bei den nächsten wahlen könnte es schon
zu spät sein
wir müssen also jetzt unbedingt dringend
was tun und und das können wir halt in
denen wir heute wirklich an die wahl und
gehen ich finde das gar nicht ob ich
schon gesagt habe oder ist diese nicht
gelistet ist eben vorhin gesagt habe wir
sind der souverän wir können entscheiden
wir sind quasi die könige und königinnen
von deutschland und europa und können
bestimmen wie das parlament eben
zusammengesetzt ist dann wenn wir
gewählt haben und ich
würde mich tierisch freuen wenn wir
wirklich es hinbekommen dass das
parlament doch ein wenig anders
zusammengesetzt wird und wir vielleicht
durch diese etwas andere zusammensetzung
es hinkriegen das wirklich hier in
europa der klimawandel ja wirklich mit
dass das wird zumindest unseren beitrag
dazu leisten um ihn endlich zu stoppen
und vielleicht das klimaziel von einer
temperatur steigerung von nur in
anführungszeichen 1,5 erreichen
hier kamen gerade ein kommentar wo ich
wirklich sagen muss genau das hat mich
beschäftigt partei gründen vielleicht
mit youtube ja was wäre eigentlich wenn
wir eine partei gründen würden wenn wir
sagen würden so jetzt nehmen was in die
hand ja und viele jungwähler die
vielleicht schon in 1 23 jahren wählen
könnten würden dann vielleicht diese
partei wählen und so dazu beitragen dass
ich wirklich etwas ändert weil es muss
sich etwas ändern das steht schon fest
weil wenn es so weiter geht dann wird
vom massensterben kommen und nicht nur
zum massensterben der zu
massenaussterben der tiere sondern es
wird auch uns menschen betreffen und
auch das was jetzt was wir jetzt sehen
die flüchtlingswelle nach europa hat mit
dem klimawandel bereits schon zu tun und
das wird noch schlimmer
also wir müssen heute handeln und das
sind wir wir
wir können nicht immer die verantwortung
auf die politikerinnen und politiker
schieben sondern wir müssen selber die
verantwortung tragen und zwar indem wir
wählen gehen und wenn wir dann nicht
wählen waren dann müssen wir uns ja auch
zu schreiben dass wir dafür
verantwortlich sind dass das so passiert
wie es passiert also
unbedingt heute in die wahllokale gehen
es ist jetzt 14 uhr dh noch vier stunden
sind zeit jeder der jetzt vielleicht
noch sagt auch thuja war es auch nicht
kann sich jetzt noch umentscheiden ich
würde mal sagen er wird jeder wird ja
noch ungefähr im umkreis sich befinden
von vier stunden anfahrt zu seinem
wahllokal also los geht's nehmt eure
beine in die hand oder eben was ich
vorhin schon gesagt habe das telefon
ruft verwandte bekannte freunde eltern
großeltern und so weiter an und
überzeugt sie davon wählen zu gehen
davon ja wählen zu gehen und überzeugte
davon vor allem dingen auch parteien zu
wählen die sich massiv gegen den
klimawandel einsetzen und ja vielleicht
uns mithelfen durch ihre stimme noch
etwas zu ändern und ich appelliere an
euch alle auch überlegt mal was ihr
selber macht wie kommt ihr zur schule
lasst ihr euch im suv eurer eltern zur
schule fahren fahrt ihr vielleicht mehr
fahrrad römer hier nutzt ihr zb so was
hier von mobile hier in berlin gibt es
an jeder ecke überhaupt fahren hier sehr
viele leute rat und das ist richtig gut
für die umwelt
und da solltet ihr euch selber mal die
nase packen ich fliege inzwischen
wirklich kaum noch nur wenn es gar nicht
anders geht fahre ausschließlich zug bei
langen strecken und hier in der stadt
habe ich einen kleinen elektro smart den
kann ich euch gleich mal zeigen ja und
so kann jeder etwas tun und wir sollten
es wirklich tun
und ja wir sollten uns wirklich tun weil
wir sind ansonsten verantwortlich vor
allem das freiwillig machen wenn er
freiwillig sagen wir wollen eine dicke
cara fahren und es nämlich wichtig und
es so sexy und sonst was
dann müssen wir uns wirklich dann sind
wir wirklich schuldig
und da kann ich das ist schon also ich
habe gibt journalisten und
journalistinnen jetzt die man selber so
das experiment machen ob man wirklich
sagen es war schon ein bisschen peinlich
das ist ein experiment ist klimaneutral
oder klimafreundlich zu leben und
feststellen das ist gar nicht so schlimm
und wenn politiker heute sagen ja aber
das kann sich ja nicht wie auf dem land
die leute und wir können ja sonst kommen
ja nicht so weg ja liebe politik dann
ändert das mal sorgt man dafür dass
ordentlicher person öffentlicher
personennahverkehr auf dem land
existiert das könnt ihr nämlich dazu
habt ihr die möglichkeiten und saß dann
da die leute zu instrumentalisieren die
schlechte verkehrsanbindung auf dem land
haben das ist wirklich ganz miese
propaganda also wir brauchen dringend
eine politik die etwas gegen den
klimawandel tun und das jetzt und sofort
und wie gesagt wenn er nicht selber
gehen können wenn er nicht selber wählen
könnt dann ruft eure eltern großeltern
verwandte bekannt und sowohl an und
macht das so ich glaube ich habe jetzt
eine menge gesagt zu diesem thema ach ja
ich wollte ihr euch ja noch meinen
kleinen smart zeigen noch 20 meter muss
ich da hingehen ja und dann würde ich
sagen nehmt eure füße in die hand rein
in die hand wie heißt das noch mal das
idm nein also macht euch sputet euch und
bietet euch und geht zu ihrem wahllokal
gebt eure stimme ab und ich finde dann
wenn man seine pflicht getan hat kann
man auch viel ruhiger
nachts schlafen also man kann sowieso
nicht ruhig schlafen wenn man die ganze
entwicklung sieht aber wenn man
zumindest das getan hat was nötig ist
und was man getan haben kann dann finde
ich geht das schon etwas besser so jetzt
sehe ich meinen smart auch schon und
dann drehe ich das jetzt auch mal um so
und da ist er ja geht wählt den ältesten
26 der cdu ja das ist sehr lustig ja den
kann man wählen kann man aber auch
lassen
soja mir kennzeichen mit dem wunderbaren
am ende ja sehr hübsches flottes gefährt
vor allen dingen hier mit man kann das
dach öffnen und jack und hinten fehlt
etwas
das ist der auspuff ja und das dank ich
mit regenerativen energien also lade es
und dementsprechend habe ich einen
relativ kleinen fußabdruck also co2
fußabdruck wer in der karbon auch in
einer kleinen wohnung ich brauche nicht
so groß hat ein großes büro und viele
leute aber arbeiten und von daher
überprüft das mag kann man ja in der im
web machen co2 fußabdruck mal checken
und ja also dann würde ich mal sagen an
dieser stelle viel spaß heute noch beim
stimme abgeben
bis dann bleibt dran